brian Stelter Don Lemon Anderson Cooper
they focused on Mike Flynn and Russia
Russia Russia for two years and they
want you to forget about it now as they
move on to inflated coronavirus death
rates bringing on non-scientists and
hosting town halls with greta not
because they are trying to fulfill their
journalistic obligations in informing
you but precisely because they do not
want you informed so let's talk about
Mike Flynn I know Jill has been
following it really closely I have I
have I have been following it closely I
will tell you I don't care I have not
that I don't care I have fatigue in the
sense that when this happened with
Russia I was always saying all right
after the first two months I said this
isn't gonna go anywhere it's a crock
they're going to keep trotting out new
information it's inconsequential he'll
probably be impeached it won't go to the
Senate nothing will happen in this case
sure Obama did horrible stuff do I think
he's gonna be charged right now where's
it gonna go so let's just give you what
you need to know so you understand the
corruption at play that being said you
don't need to always know every single
new development because it gets to the
point where you're so granular it's it's
hard to understand the scope it here's
the scope of it an outgoing
administration spied and use the FBI as
a political arm to try and get a man in
jail would you scare the hell out of
most everybody should scare the hell out
of most everybody let me give you a
little more info now the Justice
Department so they obviously know they
drop the charges against Michael Flynn
and now the attention is turned to how
Barack Obama and the outgoing
administration how they sort of unfairly
or some people allege illegally targeted
Trump's administration so of course you
have people on the left in the media
basically everyone outside of here and
some some radio shows reporting on this
the whole thing like I said the whole
umbrella which is a real disservice to
Americans as a conspiracy theory it's so
disappointing to look at what we're
seeing from right-wing media these days
where there's such an obsession so bad
that the news people treating the
Michael Quinn store like it's a don't
you waste you're watching poppy Harlow
right now
friends the other morning Friday morning
right before the unemployment rate
numbers came out he talked about the
Flint case for 20 minutes those happy
days are here again with a brand new
conspiracy that Trump and Fox News are
calling Obama gains some terrible things
happening there to never be allowed to
happen in our country again and you'll
be seeing what's going on over the next
over the coming weeks but and I wish
you'd write honestly about it but
unfortunately you choose to do so we'll
see what happens you'll see what it is
it's coming out in the next few weeks
you know what it is I don't can you tell
us I can't actually praise no meaning
except to predecessor with some very
nebulous
so let's go through this since they're
so puzzled let's kind of lay out the
timeline the Obama heir FBI right they
were out to get Flynn from the beginning
they listened to his phone calls while
he was on vacation which would later be
used in really what amounts to a perjury
trap the goal was getting Flynn to be
fired or to be in prison so bill pre
step who's a doctor as a doctor bosses
stroke in truth good say how do you
prove it
strides okay I don't know do I don't
trust him fin buddies Russian agent it's
in the notes read what is our goal truth
slash admission to get him or to get him
to lie so we can prosecute or get him
fired question mark no I understand
that's been shared out of context and
they tried to argue that so let's go on
down the list the FBI they were moving
to close the investigation early 2017
because I didn't find anything and then
Pete stroke interviews some people heat
and then he intervened actually to up to
make sure the operation continued with
the FBI so they were going on there's
nothing here we're gonna close it then
he personally stepped into no no no
we're gonna we're gonna make sure that
we find something so really what did it
amount to that's kind of hopefully does
that people understand that timeline the
base happen calls what they were doing
with Flynn and what it amounted to what
okay two lies that he didn't actually
ask the Russian ambassador to refrain to
not respond to sanctions that were being
imposed by Barack Obama and then he said
that he only asked how Russia would vote
on a resolution that involved Israel but
a parent
he actually asked them to vote against
or delay the resolution which by the way
is not entirely outside the realm of his
job let's keep going you think maybe
Flynn was lying agents didn't think
Flynn was Londo in 2017 Comey testified
the interviewing
yeah the interviewing agents that Flynn
had not made intentional misstatements
right that they had concluded these guys
testified call me any time he shows up
you got that people just go [ __ ] and I
feel bad for him because I thought he
was hated by the left he was hated by
the right but you've gone meat you've
earned this yeah he screwed up in every
way possible I think then Comey later
denied this but a Washington Post even
fact checked him on it whatever it is
they do Pinocchio yeah wash my house you
know it really didn't like we have to
that was really hard for them it's alive
can we this was my primary question
early on big and I asked Donald Trump
jr. when we were doing the CNN chin
because at this point we didn't have all
the information I said okay if he isn't
it what why did the guy plead guilty and
you know this probably people don't
always plead guilty because they're
guilty sure absolutely
I mean the entire system is set up to be
an adversarial system right the
prosecutors are literally their job is
to be aggressive in doing what you're
doing to you the end right and then by
the same point you know the defense
attorneys have to do the same thing and
when you're you know I don't do criminal
law but when you're the same thing
applies both civil and criminal if you
are trying to get to an end and there's
gonna be a worse harm than pleading
guilty like will plead guilty all the
time right
even if they hadn't done that particular
act that they're accused of or maybe
they did something you know related but
not as gross of a violation like they
did leave the ironing on and they don't
want to pay the piper
sure someone else was smoking in bed
right I mean right yeah I did but that
wasn't actually what let but fine or
living in bed and that's how they took
out the Mamas and Papas it's a tragedy
oh my god again so Flynn what we said
it's severe in that they threatened to
go after Flynn's son because that's why
he pled guilty yes they wouldn't
prosecute his son Joe Biden vice
president former vice president Joe
and early onset dementia example has
said repeatedly that he knew nothing
about the Flint investigation so what
did you know about those moves to
investigate Michael Flynn and was there
anything improper done I know nothing
about those moves to investigate Michael
Flynn number one number two this is all
about diversion I was aware that there
was that there they had asked for an
investigation but that's all I know
about it and I don't think anything else
there's no follow he just said I don't
think anything else ever he's like
please in the interview that's all going
to be a one question interview I would
like to think something else but I can't
but I can't think anything else so now
by the way in case you do some
foreshadowing it's been revealed by
documents that we have a but can bring
up an overlay there's a dozen obama
officials including Biden and CIA
director John Brennan that they
requested the unmasking of Michael Flynn
intelligence reports so it wasn't just
that they were involved or they knew
they were the ones who made the request
now here's my question I know you have a
point but here's my question bill
because we're kind of in this right now
with the where we used to be with a
Hillary Clinton emails and a lot of
people just sort of would speculate they
didn't really know yeah
when Joe Biden says I don't I know
nothing I know nothing and now we
verifiably can see that he was actually
the one who requested it what
ramifications are there any if any
criminally none I'm probably done well
and we explain well let me explain why
that's none criminally because he wasn't
under oath there right no if you were
gonna go through the perjury route or
you know could he had been questioned
about it but in terms of actual criminal
penalty I mean one no one's listening it
was a Stephanopoulos I was asking the
question I don't know yeah I don't know
like nobody's watching that anyway but
it doesn't have the place right if
you're gonna there are different
penalties for telling a lie outside of a
court or under not under oath and the
rest under oath the very reason being
perjury but that's not to say that there
can't still be consequences yeah
later like if he were ever to show up to
a debate you know if we were to remember
anything but if you were to say what he
just said under oath would it be a
problem that would be a problem there's
get he's not gonna
that he'll do it again no show in front
of a jury but I know nothing that we've
seen this act before guilty something
else she knows that someone's gonna
happen is he's gonna start doing some of
the things that he's complaining about
Trump doing right he's gonna say well
you're not coming to oh well I I can't
come testify I'm busy with other things
no can't open my records just like with
Terry Reid right he's like right no you
know I know that I gave all of these
records to a university so they're
already not you know completely private
but I don't want anyone else looking god
forbid we actually look at the
allegations or you can send your record
you just sent a Dexter's Lab booklet of
scratch and sniff stickers he's I don't
mean to send that please send them back
don't be like me don't be another reason
I'm exhausted with it it's because we
work in this sphere and and really you
could probably take about three pieces
of information that we just and you
would have enough of the picture and
this is why the media focuses on these
things for example this is exactly why
you see brian Stelter after nothing but
russian collusion for month really for
the entire administration Joe years I'm
actually under playing it by saying
months and now saying with coronavirus
after impeachment didn't stick the
Republicans are obsessed with Russia why
don't you move on this my brian Stelter
[Laughter]
I mean maybe I'll be more 200 pounds I'm
not a method actor and I'm not that
committed to this show they talk about
this thing going on now we want to
distract people with Russia for the
longest time they wanted to keep this
going to get as granular as possible
because they know you can't keep track
of it they know it's exhausting and they
know that most Americans want to get a
snapshot and want to get a macro picture
and I don't mean that you shouldn't be
informed of course you should inform
yourself you should get as granular as
you can you should be as informed as
possible but there's a lot of
information out there that is
unnecessary because it's either
completely untrue as we've seen with the
Mike Flynn case in other words
everything that we knew everything that
we knew about Mike Flynn up until the
last month
pretty much false wrong and it was drip
drip drip drip drip drip like a Chinese
water torture for a long
I'm to the point where you go well we
must accept it as true and then you get
tired you're not paying attention
anymore and unless there was someone
like a bar here to kind of reveal this
you would have gone on your merry way
thinking that Flynn was guilty of
borderline treason and it's not true
that's by design and unfortunately we
have a 24-hour cable news cycle with
talentless fat bags like brian Stelter
who focused on nothing but this
precisely because they want to do the
opposite of their job description brian
Stelter Don Lemon Anderson Cooper they
focused on Mike Flynn and Russia Russia
Russia for two years and they want you
to forget about it now as they move on
to inflated coronavirus death rates
bringing on non-scientists and hosting
town halls with greta not because they
are trying to fulfill their journalistic
obligations in informing you but
precisely because they do not want you
informed and I attributed motive here
yeah I am after I rarely do that after
several years of we what we now know to
be verifiable lies and now it's just
ignore that ignore what's behind the
curtain
no I understand how you can get
overwhelmed here's what's not
overwhelming here's something that I can
say confidently and you don't need to
worry about getting wrong everything
they said for two years wrong or lies
lies or wrong take your pick guess who I
am
I'm Josh Hartnett bet you didn't think
you'd see that face in a while this is
what we call an end card which is where
I tell you that you should subscribe if
you liked this video or click one of
these other videos that you may like hit
the notification bell of course join mug
club because that's what allows us to
continue doing these videos and just so
you know youtube actually is created a
new policy where they might start
outright banning channels that are no
longer commercially viable which means
that this is merely a figment of your
imagination